αμην γίνονται και αντικίνητρα δί να μην εξασφαλειτιζει κάποιους το μέλλον του και μετά αφού
είμαι εξασφαλισμένος με πάσει στολείναικάτι ανάόλογο που είχε γίνει και στην ελλάδα και ι αυτόνές
σταματήσασ θα τιθμάμε γνωρίζω ότι παλιά στην ελλάδα εκαττιζες εθυβικόν αγκόσουμε πρωτάθημα με στην οκτάδαν
που για κάποιο θμαατς αν υπηρες πανε σν ημόα επηρεσία όπό ότε ν υπήρχει λόγος
να συνέχεισμετά τα είκοσισου να γίνουν να υπάρχουν κίνητρα να μην ν αντικίνι τράμους ο
κυριάπος βρή και δυσκολίες ώστε να τον κάνουν να σκεφτεί να τα παρατήσει πολλές πολλές
και δε το μόνο που πρώ να σου πω γιατί δεν θέλω να κάποιουν να
σχοληθώ τι είχε προηγηθεί όλοι μας αντιμετωπίζουμε τς σκολές ακόμα και τα παιδία τώρα που
ίναι έχουν αλλάξει πάρα πολύ τα εδομένα θεωρώ ότι βρίσκουμ πολλές δυσκολίες το ότιο λάτρία
δεν αχρόνουν πριο τους ολιμπιακούς πρώτιμου χρονιά φαντάρος το ότιο λιαστρα είπα ότι σταματο δεν
αντέχωιατή την κατάσταση υπήρχαν αρκετές αδικίες υπήρχαν παράλογα πράγματα είχα φτάσει πραγματικά χα φτάσει στη
στο αμήν που λέμπαρατό κάποιο θρώποι ήτανδίπλαμου ε πείες αν συνέχισα και το ίχλστεθερα λαβαμέρος
τους τον εμπιακούς νομίζωμο και ο γο νεότερος αθελήτης στύπου σίγουρα που έλαβε μέρος στον
εμπιακούς αγόνες οι το κράτος θεωρίς ότι δίνητα εφόδια τους αθλητες στους νέους νθλητές οι
οποι σήμερα αποφασίζουμε ότι θέλουν να γίνουν επαγγελματίες αθλήτες γιατ μόνο αυτό να κάνδίνειτα εφόδια
ωστε να μη κάνουν τιπλές κετριπλέσκέψεις και ο στόχος τους να είναι οι διάκρίσης το
άθλημα που θα γωνίζονται να σου πω θυσιάκιτέξνα τι γίνεται πολύς λόγους αντο κράτος στηρίζει
αν το κρτος δίνι χρήματα στις όμως πουνδίς τυς αθλητές και λοιπά